on the question of our our policymakers
smart enough and for that panel I would
like to introduce Matthias verenia CEO
of noble media who is our moderator mr.
Lindstrom who CEO of Doberman and Mikkel
damper who is Sweden's Minister for
enterprise welcome all new Colombo
Minister of enterprise and innovation
welcome back to real with dialogue back
again last year we invited you as I
think I said the ideal guest to talk
about policymaking when it came to an
aging society since then you have
handled a government crisis you have
restored Sweden's reputation in Arabic
countries you have put Sweden into a neo
industrialization era if you have
started innovation advisory boards and
if I read the papers correct i think
Sweden's doing pretty well from an
economic perspective you must be pretty
smart hahaha I think my teenage
daughters might disagree they don't
think I get it all the time but more
seriously I think in these times when we
see big challenges I think you must see
that no woman or man can have the brains
themselves you have to cooperate I think
the most important thing for a
politician is to be smart enough to
listen to actually understand what's
happening and to cooperate with
researchers or or business women or our
students little Islam I don't have to
ask you if you're smart I know that
already and you are a very successful
CEO of doberman a service design company
you are an entrepreneur who have proven
yourself many many times but lately you
have become very involved in so the
policy-making closed areas you are now
the industry or Chancellor of industry
you are a very active in in the public
debate why why have you with your
background decided to activate yourself
too much it's not really a choice I
think that for me it's not beneficial to
be in in different segments of our
society I think that since we are all
humans we need to contribute with what
we have and when I was asked them you
know being allowed to collaborate it's
something I have to do with your
background which i think is sort of
non-political what have you learned that
you think or you almost or you think
that can or should be useful when it
comes to policy making first of all
since I'm an entrepreneur I'm a doer and
I think that many times I see in policy
making a lot of talking and where I can
contribute and I felt that I can
contribute is kind of in the doing
making suggesting action and in my other
capacity which is more of design it's a
nonlinear creative way of solving
problems and I think that sometimes may
be helpful to maybe bring that to the
table thanks we were in Singapore a few
weeks ago and met with the Minister of
Education and Skills and me and the
Swedish ambassador tried to invite him
to Sweden because we thought that it
would be good for him to come to Sweden
and and be inspired and he has it very
politely I said I'm sure that sweetness
a nice country but what should i why
should i go there what can you learn us
we were a little bit surprised by that
answer Maikel what do you think that we
should have answered first of all I
think it's quite telling the question
it's in itself because I sweetnesses
helix Hughley Hughley successful on a
global scale when it comes to innovation
or business but I would never dream of
saying that I would not listen to what
other good countries are doing to
actually learn from them so I I think
it's a mistake so not being really
active on a global scale to actually see
what other countries are doing well I
think that's a specter that we should
always have in Sweden
we're good but we can learn from others
and we see that other countries are
running quite fast but if you look at
the advantages of Sweden i would say
that we were highly innovative country
we top right but where I wouldn't
measure that yeah we're top three in the
world the top one in European Union when
you measure innovation but I'm always
saying here at home in Sweden at least
that measurement is not totally the best
way to look at it because it's a lot of
input values it's not the output values
and that's why we need entrepreneurs
like Lisa to actually see how to
transform all the knowledge in the
Swedish society into new things new ways
of thinking produce or change your
organization that's what that's still we
have a way to go but well sweet needs a
front runner we have a strong research
tradition and quality we have also a
very large number of big global
companies and then we have the vibrant
startup scene in Sweden in the digital
field so of course it's interesting to
actually see that Sweden now is
competing with Silicon Valley in
producing unicorns million-dollar words
billion dollar works companies globally
so of course it's interesting but I'm
quite humble because I think always
Sweden can learn from other countries
that are doing very well on the global
scene and Singapore is of course one one
country to look at Lissa what would you
like Sweden to be able or us to be able
to answer in five years time when I've
listened to all the advices that you
have come up with i would love singapore
and other countries to say hmmm i really
admire the way that sweden is taking
care of all the engagement in the
society and work through all different
segments policy or in academia and large
and small companies to solve some really
critical mega trends like climate change
or our demographical situation maybe
currently our refugee crisis and to say
hmmm interesting that they did not only
give that to the politicians that they
actually worked with their innovative
way to solve this together we must go
there in there
may ask add just one thing I think
that's totally correct what Lisa are
saying but it's also when you look to
the future what actually attracts
innovation I think society will be an
even more important thing quality of
life we see now that Spotify is
recruiting globally on parental leave to
actually get young people want to work
it Spotify because they get time also
with the children and you can recruit
both men and women to your companies and
I think this kind of societal questions
will be more important in the global
competition because innovation always
comes down to people and talent and
passion and that's why I think societies
also play a part and we're waiting what
where do I want to live where do I want
to go to actually fulfill my dream so if
we can both take on the societal
challenges together but also create a
society where people want to be and live
I think that's a great asset so sweet I
think we can do a lot of society but
together with private companies or
academia to try to always try to win to
find this kind of win-win situation
where we cooperate but society at the
whole I think we have now challenges
when it comes to to the educational
system in Sweden actually I always say
that no matter what kind of what kind of
meeting I go to in Sweden or what kind
of company I meet i say in the long run
we have to be able to compete when it
comes to education so I think for
Sweden's perspective I think the
investments we're now planning to do in
teachers are the most important thing to
actually give the educational system in
Sweden are left because we have to agree
that teachers are perhaps the most
important occupation you can find
because they're giving our children the
starting in life on a good way so I
think this is the main challenge for
Sweden out to actually turn the school
system around and create a really good
and you
a school system that gives allows
everyone to fulfill their own potential
I think that's the most important thing
for swing for the future you have this
you have this school sector or you can
call it the academic world you have the
policy-making world and you have the
private sector how do you think that
those three can or should work even
closer together Lisa from your
perspective first of all I think that we
should see more of action again what
type of action so that instead of having
maybe the business world asking for and
making a wish list to the politicians
rather say here's where we can
contribute and and start to build things
together but secondly I think it's also
important that we think of what are the
different roles so for example even if
we see all these companies and I also
represent that where we could help there
is no promise that that businesses will
be here forever whereas we will have
government forever so we need to also
divide you know what is it that you're
responsible for and what is it that I'm
responsible for and one of the questions
that we saw here is privacy and in
making sure that you know that there are
conditions to make sure that we can also
live in a safe society and that's kind
of moral maybe your row so so big both
collaborate but also be clear on
responsibilities right when we talk
about this this area the future of
intelligence it's easy to be very
positive to look at all the
possibilities that that opens up and we
saw this morning that this is a very
optimistic crowd was it a six point one
percent that that saw this as a mainly
positive development but of course there
is a negative side as well so a new
mechanism reports saying that forty-five
percent of all activities that are
involved in labor will be affected by
this this future and of course there
will be people made redundant and there
will be a lot of changes from from your
perspective how do you look upon it lisa
is it prime
a positive development or do you see
threats as well it's a challenging
development you know in the way that we
need to have faster changes in our
workforce meaning that you cannot have
the same job for your whole life meaning
that companies need to be super flexible
in thinking of what their capacity their
talent should do over time so even if
people will change their jobs forty five
percent of them it's not for me it's not
that they will not have a job they will
have a different job and we need to have
a culture and we need to have a mindset
in people's minds that I need to
contribute in that change and we need to
have business leaders who are super
flexible to change when it comes to that
and that's challenging Miguel how do you
think from your perspective afraid of
losing jobs I see that many people in
the Swedish society and also in other
countries are afraid of new technologies
they see the challenges that lie ahead
and feel only that they see the risk of
losing jobs I see yes there is
structural change I think since we took
office in this government I think
400,000 jobs has disappeared in Sweden
400,000 jobs but on the same time in
credit 480,000 job has been created
during this time so there is a massive
structural change all the time on the
labour market I usually say when I go
abroad to other countries that Sweden
has the black belt in structural change
and that's something good because we
have decided in Sweden that we won't
defend old jobs but we defend people in
change so if they lose their job they
should feel that they have new rights to
skills or education to go further or
they have a solid insurance system that
they don't have to leave their kids or
their house because they get unemployed
because they feel security in change I
think that's a very relevant aspect of
this situation now where change is
happening faster people must follow and
then you have to not be afraid of change
but as feel that there is a security in
change so I think Sweden has a good
model
as well are you prepared to handle that
change these sort of anymore we have to
do more because basically we've always
talked about basic skills now we talked
about different skills also on people
that have a university degree might be
be forced to take a different core an
extra cores to actually fit in on labor
market to transform so I think the
concept of lifelong learning is being
really challenged by this rapid
transformation I think Sweden has a lot
more to do here to actually keep up the
pace and I think other countries are
doing more now so we cannot rely that
Sweden has a top position I think we
have to do more and I think we need with
your teachers to think of less than that
people are experts and more of in a
collaborative way how can you teach
people how to learn and not only kids
but also within companies lifelong
learning yeah McCallum little instrum
thank you so much for coming tunable
dialogue and i'm sure i will see you
next year as well no matter what topic